marrant personne n'a voulu je débute et
personnes deux modes 1966 jacques brel
est au sommet de sa gloire il n'a que 37
ans et ça fait 15 ans qu'ils donnent des
concerts il est habité par la scène et
pourtant il annonce que cette tournée
sera la dernière
fini les représentations les tournées
terminé les concerts impensable pour les
journalistes
quinze ans je me prépare depuis que j'ai
débuté avant le ces en débutant que
qu'on va s'arrêter et puis j'ai un
caractère tels que je veux bien sûr
j'avais de regretter bien sûr ça n'a pas
d'importance si vous êtes sûr absolument
surmonter changer d'avis non il ne
changera pas d'avis et expliquent cette
envie d'ailleurs c'est pour aller voir
c'est pour avoir le temps d'aimer
justement j'ai un rythme de vie où j'ai
peut-être plus très bien entendu mais
j'ai envie d'aller voir de regarder de
m'offrir le plan de moteurs fin janvier
ça
[Musique]
s'appelle la liberté la liberté et le
défi de se lancer dans d'autres
expériences artistiques
j'avais il faut il faut faire des choses
dangereuses faut faire des choses qu'on
ne s'est pas encore fait il s'essaye à
la comédie musicale au jeu d'acteur et
même de réalisateur sur le tournage du
film l'emmerdeur edouard molinaro
explique cette envie de remise en
question perpétuelle
c'est quelqu'un qui laisse les choses
qui regarde qui regarde devant
il a abandonné le métier de chanteur
pour devenir comme comédien il a
abandonné où ils abandonnent le métier
de comédien pour devenir metteur en
scène il abandonnera le métier de
metteur en scène peut devenir pilote
qu'est-ce qui sera après avoir été
pilote quatre navigateurs gens sérieux
exactement navigateur direction les îles
marquises là-bas jacques brel malades se
consacre à l'écriture d'un dernier album
à partir de demain
beaucoup d'entre vous poseront ce disque
sur leurs platines avec je crois une
certaine émotion
c'est le dernier brel un an plus tard
une embolie pulmonaire en porte
l'artiste aventuriers aura-t-il accéder
à son inaccessible étoile comme un porc
[Musique]